[Music]
[Applause]
here's how the survey works we asked
three celebrities to complete a phrase
our first phrase was my favorite
children's book is Michael Cera wrote
Winnie the Pooh nice Pierce Morgan wrote
The Giving Tree
Mitt Romney wrote Heidi bucks and the
three Cayman Islands no serious
Republican wants to see Mitt Romney
wrote another four years of Obama Bobby
Jindal wrote the implementation of the
health care law
chris Christie wrote my staged
reenactment of the film magic not true I
want to see that very badly oh you're
not a serious room no yes you know I
never know I think this will be the year
I finally mark walberg
learned to play guitar Russell Brand
wrote cut my hair Justin Bieber wrote
start menstruating
remember these are their answers New
York Knicks Jason Kidd slamming his car
into a telephone pole is Charles Barkley
wrote a private matter that fortunately
didn't hurt anyone
Magic Johnson wrote something he'll have
to face consequences for Jason Kidd
wrote a perfect metaphor for the coming
Knicks season at this year's Olympics
I'll be rooting for my home country of
Hugh Jackman wrote Australia Kate
Beckinsale United Kingdom Lindsay Lohan
wrote trainwreck Sylvania P the phrase I
always live by is Christina Hendricks
wrote judge not lest ye be judged
Adam Sandler wrote do unto others as you
would have them do unto you Barack Obama
wrote teach a man to fish
I killed Osama bin Laden
remember it going that way now Katie
Holmes leaving Scientology in favor of
the Catholic Church was Sharon Osbourne
wrote an act of modern bravery way
Michelle wrote proof that long-held
beliefs are hard to shake Katie Holmes
wrote can't talk now running away from
spaceship with giant vacuum oh hi huh I
hope I'm an inspiration to my fellow
dave grohl wrote musicians bryan
cranston wrote actors Steven Tyler wrote
scarecrow prostitutes
before I accept a movie role I usually
need Jon Hamm wrote to read the script
Tom Hanks wrote to meet the director
Nicholas Cage wrote the money my my
secret to looking this way is Jennifer
Aniston wrote lots of yoga classes Rose
era Dustin wrote 10 hours of sleep each
night mob wife pig Angie wrote gorillas
stem cells
[Music]
[Applause]
and finally unlike me I hope my kids
won't have to Julie Bowen wrote
struggled to afford health care don
cheadle wrote ponder the value of
equality Larry King wrote speak at
countless brontosaurus funeral
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we learned a lot we've learned
absolutely nothing but peace is a huge
wasted time